it has begun war is coming
so why are you here to save all people
we must fight together can we trust him
they're beasts they should all be
destroyed are you sure that
we'll protect the kingdom you and I we
will try my friend
warcraft rated pg-13
hey youtubers is charlie new Warcraft
trailer so let's break it down then we
can have our survivor support group for
a PTSD from Warcraft addiction one of
the things I really love about this
warcraft movie isn't isn't it it's going
to be a lot of fun because it will is
all the warcraft stories that everyone's
going to tell in the comments and then
waiting in line standing in the theater
i used to play vanilla full-blown
addiction by burning crusade lost one of
my best girlfriends to lich king so some
of this footage is repeated from the
last trailer but we have learned a
couple new things like this body here
seems like it's lane rent you see his
wife Lady tarea here addressing the
crowd you see his son variants standing
over here no confirmation on this yet
but it does seem like the Burning Legion
plays a role in the need for the orcs to
team up with the humans like you have
duro tan who wants his people to survive
so he makes this pact with Lothar but on
both sides on both humans and orcs there
are people that really don't want this
like orgrim seems like he's going to be
something of the antagonist orc and then
you have ryan robbins character who you
might remember from arrow this season
playing Karros he's kind of like at the
Oryx who cares who gives a crap bottom
but obviously if the Burning Legion
takes down the orcs as a Roth is next we
get to see a lot of familiar places like
dollar and Cara's an now both mad even
khadgar are in the movie CAG ours madiba
Prentiss we don't really know what's
going on with the portal but but
obviously they have sequel movies
planned depending on the success of the
first movie as far as we know there's no
draw nigh in the movie so I'm not really
sure what they're going to do with the
corona character because in the game
she's secretly half drawn I half-orc but
in the movie they might be presenting
her as half-human then they might
introduce the twist like oh no your have
drawn I you're not half human and then
spin that out into the sequel stormwind
of course human capital right now I
would say like the thing that I find
most interesting is what's going on with
the Council of mages is especially in
dal ran like what is their role in this
movie because they're kind of like this
third party that literally exists above
humanity one of the few really big
things that's been missing from the last
couple of trailers is a lot of golden
he's probably going to be the one in the
movie that's responsible for opening the
portal one of the fun twists of the game
and I think they'll probably incorporate
this into the movie is that Gould on
tricks the aurochs into invading asrock
because it's like drainers dying we need
to invade asrock so that we can have
this new place to live but
really he tricks them into working for
the Burning Legion tricks them into
drinking demon blood and then they
become the green or extreme key demon
blood is what turns them green which is
kind of why I'm wondering what's going
on with thrall here who is duro tan son
duro tan and his wife seemed like they
have not drunk demon blood like they
they haven't turned green or anything
like that so why is thrall green we'll
have to find out there might be some
movie trickery at play here this big
scene here though with Luther riding on
the back of the Griffin he's flying
towards the Dark Portal it seems like
it's going to be the big final battle of
the film I'm expecting what it whatever
ends up happening after this battle to
kind of throw into whatever the sequel
might end up being like wherever they
might have gone right after this my
guess is the burning legion is going to
be the true antagonist of the film then
they would push deeper into that lure
for the second movie but you guys can
let me know like where do you want them
to go with the sequel if it ends up
happening and I think it will it's just
a question of when it's going to happen
so much of this movie is CG which is why
I think it took Blizzard so long in the
first place to find a team to make it
with them but it also means the sequel
could take up to like three years but
but I think if it makes enough money
than they can fast-track it but in
related news congratulations to the
giveaway winner if you guys didn't know
I'm giving away an epic mount
congratulations to Tesla effect you win
a gift certificate for an epic mount if
you don't play wow you still get a gift
certificate you can use it for whatever
you want just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel if you
guys want I'll continue to do a warcraft
give away so new giveaway starts now
we'll just call it a blizzard giveaway
because a lot of you might not be
playing warcraft right now but you're
playing another blizzard game so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll just announce the winner
whenever I do my next Warcraft video
because the movie is coming in june
we're probably going to start seeing a
lot more stuff from this film so I'll
start ramping up by Warcraft videos I do
have some new Deadpool footage to post
he's trying to offend as many people
around the world as possible and it is
amazing so that'll be my next video why
you guys wait for that to post in case
you haven't seen it you can click here
for my last Deadpool video here's he
makes fun of Wolverine is the most
amazing thing ever and you can click
here for my Suicide Squad trailer video
that I just posted thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you